This is the kind of arguments I get in my family. I get into my family.
These are the kinds of arguments I get into my family and with my family,
uh, on friends. Wait, hold on. I want to see this guy's name. What was his name?
Uh, Ross Geller. It says not. And that's not what I want. Eddie,
I think is who's this guy.
Yeah. Who gives a? I don't care. All right. Look, uh,
my dad went to go put some calamari.
He had two pieces of kalimari on his fork. Now this is the important I,
I like talking about.
This has nothing to do with world events or current events,
but this is seriously. The kind of stuff that I think about.
And I want to know about my dad had two Kalamaras on his fork.
Okay. One was on the fork,
obviously more than the other one. Cause one was on at first,
the other one was on it and I could tell it was on it precariously.
He didn't really poke it hard enough. Now,
when I saw him do that and not fix it, I was like, I noticed it now.
I noticed it because I'm a Charlie. Goodnight.
what is it? Pie. Okay. I'm on the NBC lineup in 2003.
I'm a pie baby. So I saw it and I thought, well,
he's been dipping them in the sauce. It's on precariously. He's not going to,
he's going to lose it in the sauce. All right. Now I'm watching him do it.
Sure enough. He goes to dip it in, loses it in the sauce.
There's still some loses. One of them in the sauce.
There's still the other calamari.
Or if you're a piece of calamari in America, you say it like that.
If you're tiny, say Kalamata, you're not a piece of. If you're in here, he said,
cut them out of your piece of. Okay.
So there's some sauce on the one that's not in the sauce would that's
doused obviously in the sauce. So there's one and he eats it and then I go, Oh,
you didn't know that was going to happen. And he says, huh?
And I said, you didn't know you're going to lose that one in the sauce.
And he says, I don't care. And I said,
and then he goes and grabs it out of the sauce with the fork and puts in his
mouth. I said, there's too much sauce on that one. Huh? And he says, nah,
now, um, you know, it's like, Whoa, first of all,
have a opinion about something that okay.
Have a opinion about something. All right.
If you're going to put a fork in a kalimari put it in the Kalamara.
If you want to get to Kalamara Kalamaras poke the whole two.
Kalamaras all right. If you're going to dip it in the sauce, do that.
If you're gonna dip it in the sauce, for sure.
Poke the two column Mari's all right.
This guy has one calamari in the,
and another one dangling off. Like it's a boogie. All right.
Dips it in leaves.
The one in the sauce eats the original one that was on low. And I say,
I didn't know, that was going to happen. And he looks at me and he says,
I don't care. And then he eats it. And I said,
there's too much sauce on that one too. Huh? He says, no, I liked it. Oh, Holy,
dude,
this kind of thing is not something that I live. Alright, dude.
I, I said to him, you didn't, again.
I said, you didn't know that you were going to lose that calamari in the sauce.
And he says, I don't care that it happened. And I said, dad,
that's not the question I'm asking you. Did, you know,
you were going to lose the calamari and the sauce. And he said, no,
I don't think I did. And I said, well,
that's what makes you a bad detective and me a good detective man. And he says,
but I didn't think about it. And I didn't care. And I said.
[Inaudible].
I actually don't remember what I said at that point.
But I do remember him then taking the calamari
in the thing and eating it. And I said,
that's too much sauce on that calamari. And you know it. And he says, no,
I liked it.
And then the next thing he did was take kalimari out of the
Kalamara ball and put it in his mouth with no sauce, dude.
Okay.
Like you dude,
how much sauce do you want on each kalimari you don't do it.
How funny is it that he was just like carefree chilling. Oh,
I want some sauce on this calamari. I want total sauce on this.
Kalimari and you know what? Ooh, let me go nuts and have no sauce on this
dude. Oh my God, man. Find out the way, dude. He's 72.
How do you, like, how do you like to eat calamari?
How much sauce you like on the calendar?
This guy's just Willy nilly trying to scoop out Kalamaras like, it's that,
what's that thing that we try to grab a Pokemon or a
Teletubby out of a thing and you can never do it because you always grab it out
of the, you put in a quarter and you grab it and you got it a little bit.
And you're like, Oh, cut it over to the drop it. And then it drops too soon.
What do you call that thing and have a car at a carnival? What is it?
Grabbing game crane. Crane. That's what it is.
This guy's just doesn't know how he likes his calamari. He's 72 years old.
Didn't know how to like his calamari.
Do you best believe when I get a ice cream sundae? I tell him
if anything comes with sauce, dude, you put the sauce on the side.
I'll take the with the spoon and I'll decide how much sauce goes on each bite
dude. And I'm not even 40.
And I know that I'm the young that's coming to you straight from the youngest
man alive. I'm the youngest man you've ever met. Dude.
I'm the youngest man you've ever heard of.
And I know this and my 72 year old father is just Willy nilly dropping calamari
everywhere. And then sometimes just tossing them in his mouth.
That gets a chip with no sauce or a popcorn. I should say
all. We were laughing, dude. So I'm going to post a video in a little bit.
My dad went in when he says, bye. He's so tired. First of all,
he grabs the back of my head and he says, I'll see you later.
And gives me a kiss on the cheek, which is fine. That's cool.
I like that, but it's always so high dude.
And every time he does it, I try to get on my tippy toes at the last minute.
So he misses and hits my cheek and I'm like, dad, you kiss my eye dude.
And he's like, that's not your eye. This is your eyes. This is your own.
He starts poking my eye and I'm like dad. And he was like, look, look, look,
let me just show you. This is your cheek. This is where I'm going to kiss you.
And he kisses me on the right here, dude, right here.
If you're watching the video. It's right here. Who kisses?
Somebody on the cheekbone for real. I'm a go lower dude.
Go here. Kiss buck in a year. It's like the old, a one steak sauce.
Commercial gets you here. Get you right here.
Kiss where the guy's pointing on the commercial
dude. It's so no, no it grabs. It's so aggressive and high.
Nah, let me go. Come on, come on. And then I go to kiss.
My mom and mom go right on my cheek word should be right.
Like where the teeth meet, you know?
Um, I didn't wanna, I'm gonna post that video.
It's probably on my Instagram right now.
Um, so
you gotta know how to dip your calamine, by the way. I've never had California.
My life never had calamine in my life and I won't have California in my life.
I don't think that that's the kind of thing I want to do. Dude.
Never had California in my life.
I don't do things until I regret I haven't done them. That's how it goes.
It's why I never smoked weed. That's why I never drank alcohol.
That's why I didn't lose my Virginia till I was 19.
I didn't lose my Virginia till I was 19 dude. You know why?
Because I wanted to make sure I wanted to do it. And then when I regretted,
I didn't have sex with that one girl.
One time that was when I knew I was ready and wanted to have sex.
It's like when you're shopping, you go out, ah, don't want to buy that coat.
Let me leave the shop. You leave the shop, should've bought that coat.
That's when you go back and you buy the coat now me dauntless buy the coat.
Anyway, at this point in my life.